Speaker 1: as if we don't already have enough
anti-Semitism to deal with right now.
Radical and outrageous right wing Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Green is comparing having
to wear a mask in the House of Representatives
to the Holocaust.
Green was interviewed by the Christian Broadcasting
Networks, David Brody on the Real America's
Voice TV show.
Yes, that's a real channel.
That's a real show.
Here is what she had to say.
Speaker 2: This woman is mentally ill.
You know, we can look back at a time in history
where people were told to wear a gold star
and they were definitely treated like second
class citizens, so much so that they were
put in chains and taken to gas chambers and
Nazi Germany.
And this is exactly the type of abuse that
Nancy Pelosi is talking about.
Well, let's talk about the queen of the House
of Hypocrisy.
Speaker 1: There was no pushback at all from
the interviewer, David Brody, there.
A mask mandate from mentally ill Nancy Pelosi
is like Jews being murdered in the Holocaust,
according to Marjorie Taylor Green.
Now, of course, there's no follow up from
the reporter because CBN isn't journalism,
it's merely propaganda.
And the guy really isn't a reporter.
But at the same time, to say nothing is really
not an option.
This has to be called out when something fun,
something for the greater good, like vaccination
or wearing a mask during a pandemic is being
compared to the genocide of the Jewish people.
You have to call it out and say this isn't
accurate and anybody who enables it.
In this case, it was David Brody on the Christian
Broadcasting Network enabling.
It also must be called out.
The Nazis didn't order the Jews to do things
that kept them safe.
That wasn't what went on during the Holocaust.
Rules established to protect health are not
the same as the systematic extermination of
a people.
And of course, the greater tragedy is that
this woman was elected to be a member of Congress.
It's not even clear to me that Marjorie Taylor
Greene should have a driver's license.
And there's an entire political movement that
believes she should be one of the five hundred
and thirty five federal lawmakers, hundred
senators, 435 in the House, 535 total.
There's a movement that thinks in a country
of three hundred and thirty one million.
One of the 535 leading us at the federal level
should be her that is really, really dangerous.
And this is what happens when we either look
away or we don't vote or we don't vote in
large enough numbers.
I got an email from a viewer who believes
he understands how people like Marjorie Taylor
Greene come to have a following in the first
place.
And the way he outlined it was you start with
years and years of fear mongering about You-Know-Who,
right?
Years and years and years of fear mongering
about Democrats and minorities taking advantage
of welfare programs, brown people coming here
illegally and stealing your jobs and committing
crimes, all of that fear mongering that you
know of.
You combine it with sensationalist propaganda,
news media, Fox News, OCN, Newsmax, Christian
Broadcasting Network, and then you have underfunded
education parents who don't know anything
about media literacy so they can't teach their
kids so the kids have no place to learn it.
And then you direct at the self-centered sort
of upper middle class, middle class suburbanites
like Green, you direct the propaganda at them.
Absent the education that they need, they
become deranged.
They become obsessed with protecting their
own status.
That's being threatened by, you know, Democrats,
nonexistent socialists, minorities, immigrants,
poor people, et cetera.
They identify them as the enemies.
And then in a country of three hundred and
thirty one million people, imagine this is
who ends up getting elected as one of four
hundred and thirty five members of the House,
one of five hundred and thirty five members
of the House and Senate.
It is a vile and disgusting analogy that she
makes.
She is a vile woman and I know that sometimes
the term mentally ill is used in jest or as
a slur.
But there are more and more members of Congress
referring to Marjorie Taylor Green as sick
or mentally ill, including AOC, who actually
said, quote, This is a woman that's deeply
unwell and clearly needs help.
It seems obvious that that's the case.
Some people saw what AOSIS said and they said,
oh, that's bad.
AOC is stigmatizing and making fun of mental
illness.
I don't see that at all.
At a certain point, we have to be able to
say this is not just an ignorant person with
disgusting political views.
These are ignorant political views that have
been weaponized by some kind of mental illness.
And you have enough people in this country
who either don't realize that this is an unwell
woman or they don't care.
I don't know.
It has to be OK to propose that there is a
mental illness component when it's so obviously
what's going on.
But at the same time, the mental illness component
doesn't excuse the political beliefs.
It's a double edged sword.
Calling something mental illness when it isn't
isn't a good thing to do.
At the same time, excusing bad acts because
the person seems sick or unwell.
We also can't be doing that.
It is a complicated issue, particularly in
a country where many don't have access to
proper mental health services or diagnostic
services.
And when it's heavily stigmatized and when
quite frankly, I mean, listen, I don't know
if I'll get in trouble for saying this.
There are lots of political beliefs, some
on the left, but overwhelmingly on the right
that are delusional beliefs in the literal
sense.
And so when you when you see that it actually
can be difficult to distinguish just delusional
political beliefs versus someone who is diagnosable.
I think with Marjorie Taylor Greene, it's
probably both.
And that is increasingly what we're hearing
from people who know her and who have been
targeted and by her like Alexandria Cacio
Cortez, let me know your thoughts, but a disgusting
analogy and comparison there.